oh okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica I just went through a fricken
endeavor here's a little play-by-play of
what I just underwent trying to find the
seamoth fragments which don't exist
anymore so here's my adventure brick
swan dive wah
boink okay I don't know what that is but
I think they're after me
hello propulsion cannon hell yeah I'll
take that there's a lot of fragments
over here I might as well just grab up
everything I can because one of the
what's a filtration machine why the
machine is that so Joule huh [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] off oh no you do not know you do
not I gotta find another goddamn
fragment seamoth fragment what okay what
is that huh Oh
oh that wasn't what this doesn't make
any sense at all oh I'm so confused I
had so many misconceptions about this
episode I thought I was gonna have to go
by this yep good
no Leviathan hunting for me zero hi what
are you doing in the shallow water holy
[ __ ]
hi buddy okay well while you're
distracted I'm gonna go around to the
other side and hopefully youdo you have
a friend
I've forgotten do you have a friend but
he's not right for me oh [ __ ] uh uh uh I
think you'll be fine
yummy now hide it oh that is the sound
of something that's not fine
whoa I can't even get him barring
somewhere I am of course I come over
here at night whoa what everything is
horrible
what is that god damn it okay then they
they did they entirely changed it there
are no more seamoth fragments there are
just the seamoth parts that I gotta find
wherever they blue
not particularly helpful in this
endeavor that are yeah so that happened
um I came out of that with a little more
knowledge though because now I know that
the seamoth is only found from exploded
pieces of the seamoth which um I should
have realized because that's how you get
the Cyclops now you just find the
various pieces of the Cyclops or maybe
that was how it was before and I just
don't remember but the seamoth was
definitely not that way
it was find the fragments go have fun
live your goddamn life but now we have
to deal with other things so in other
news oh [ __ ] I walked into a wasp nest
holy [ __ ] right
in other news I've got a number of new
things that I have to show you guys um
number one I found the fragments for the
scanner room there's this new device
called a rebreather that may not be new
but I've just never used it I got the
moon pool and a various number of other
things that I think oh I found the
filtration thing you guys probably saw
that my little play-by-play but the
filtration system means that I don't
look fun I won't have to deal with
taking air sacks out of the environment
and then squeezing water out of them
with my bare hands
so that's good so what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna head back and I'm gonna try
to find another wreckage where there
could possibly be is that that is ooh
that's the seamoth fragment okay cool
well that was convenient that sure did
mouth [ __ ] goddammit [ __ ] you what the
[ __ ] Oh what are you you pulsating
weirdo okay so that was fortunate now I
only need one more to be able to make
the seamoth and so that one should be in
this general area okay this is the I
think this is the no that's different
ooh there's a different one okay so if I
look around here hopefully what is
u-bolts and cannon I think I need
one of you anyway yeah there we go I got
the propulsion Canon hot tits look at me
yeah I don't need that okay so now that
I have that than in this general area
there should be another seamoth fragment
around here and then I'll behind to be
able to make the seamoth I'll give
Geoffrey Billy samurais and Marshall a
job because they've been a little
freeloaders but that's ok I love them
nonetheless and then I'll be able to
make do with everything else that I got
and I'll be able to go around the world
and not have to rely on this stupid
piece of [ __ ] which admittedly is nice
to have but god damn it is it a pain in
the ass
oh oh oh huh is that please tell me
that's not just metal that's a CMOS got
it I got it yes whoo that is terrifying
holy [ __ ] that's less terrifying this
more cool all of a sudden okay but I got
what I needed
so I have that I have a lot of new
blueprints I'm gonna make my way back to
my main base and we're gonna have a good
old time assembling a whole bunch of
materials because I've also been very
dutiful to you guys that I've farmed up
everything that I need hopefully to be
able to do these things so oh [ __ ] I did
not know that I was going that way okay
so I'm gonna be right back once I get
back to my main base not my other place
ah home sweet home so I made a few
expansions mostly just putting out more
foundations for everything else that I'm
gonna need but my next step is gonna be
the mobile actually not the moon pool
just yet because I'm pretty sure that
I'm gonna need other things besides the
moon pool as a priority I'm gonna
prioritize new things before I'm gonna
prioritize things that I've already
gotten that includes seemeth
unfortunately but that does mean that I
have a lot more opportunities to make
some pretty cool things I'm actually
pretty close to getting the Cyclops I
just need to find a few more broken
pieces here and there so in the endeavor
of getting new things for you guys look
that is but a walt water filtration
machine that sound good
I can build that right now only two
titanium that's that's literally awesome
how do I make the who do I want
everything in this main room it would be
pretty cool all right I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna say I'm not gonna go around
this way so I can't believe that I only
took two titanium no useful tracing
machine what am I gonna do how do we do
it what do we do
Wyatt oh it's already doing it oh it
looks like a water dispenser from a
goddamn gym okay so apparently I suppose
I could just put things in it but I
don't have it okay I'm gonna let this do
its thing um maybe I'm gonna put another
one in here somewhere maybe just have
kind of two water filtration machines I
mean what's the harm they only take two
titanium might as well make some more oh
it kind of made it a little crowded in
here I probably I probably should put
these in another room just because I
have this giant ass thing in the middle
of my goddamn living room and I need
these over here but this is so cool I
can just make water whatever I want
whenever I want whenever I want I'll
just meet this the water room holy [ __ ]
I've never had a whole room dedicated to
one purpose like this but yeah I'm
making a water room hot damn
look at that oh god it's sucking my
power oh no my power my bioreactor isn't
good enough for this [ __ ] okay but
that's fine I'll get a nuclear reactor
down the road but that's only one of the
things that I wanted to show you the
other thing is I need to I'll get the
names in just a second I will get the
names I needed to get one of those
because I need to make a wiring kit and
then I can make this piece of equipment
called a rebreather it doesn't even have
a texture it's a big old question mark
but with the rebreather hopefully
equipped equipped with equip wear no no
what are you wait why with me why are
you hovering me I think that's where
that would go isn't it yeah okay
I don't need the radiation helmet unless
I'm actually near by the thing so I can
put my radiation stuff
I'm gonna build a few more lockers here
real quick because I need to put names
on the walls anyway so I need okay so
the first one goes to Brandi
GAO's ear Brandi Jie who says who asks
if I had to look up the names of my
children and no I did not Jeffery Billy
samurais and Marshall are in my heart
forever I would never forget them
probably and the next one goes to make
one who said that I'm going crazy
from isolation I'd like you to try to
prove it if you can there's not enough
evidence out there on the Internet to
say otherwise the necklace goes to
Marquis mu Marquis mo um who said it
sucks to the old game got deleted but
there's new beginning do it you know all
things happen for a reason even though
sister game and it's subnautica I think
the reason was I needed upgrade
everything but thank you nonetheless and
the last one goes to mini butter who had
a whole bunch of advice thank you very
much for chatting on give me advice on
placement where I needed to put my base
so the other thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna deconstruct two of these because
holy [ __ ] all of my power is gone can I
can i construct this please thank you I
mean as much as I would love to have
these water filtration systems I kind of
fudged up on not being able to get what
I needed so the names are on the lockers
and now the next step is I need to
construct oh [ __ ] I need enameled glass
let's see I got two glass up with that
in there I need lubricant and Power Cell
we ramped that going to get the Power
Cell oh yeah I've got the Power Cell
right here Brandi's got them okay so if
I take this up up up up up up and up two
my I was easing up to Geoffrey Billy Sam
was and Marshall they should be able to
help me with what I need
hi boys sorry whoosh it's alright little
drunk didn't mean to come here drunk
again point there we go see mom's baby
and I can't name it yet but at least
I'll have it oh why do you keep building
it up in the sky like that that's cool
though you go you boys do your thing and
like how it's in the shadow of the moon
whatever that is
hello oh my baby it's been so long how
are you doing it how are you doing okay
so anyway
now give me married hello you're not
quite the USS [ __ ] duck and I'm a
newt make a new name out of it maybe you
guys can help me name the new ship once
I get the via moon pool accessed again
but I won't be able to do that just yet
because I need to do other things first
so with this I can take the seamoth and
I can go make the creatures of here
nibble on my hull until they lose their
teeth so be right back once again here
bite my butt by my butt baby bye bye
baby boo ha bunk oh no did you lose a
tooth
oh no okay so I finally got it it wasted
an enormous amount of power on my
seemeth but I finally got it I had to go
I could only get like one from every
stalker so I had to go around and find
enough stalkers to be able to get what I
need but I do have it so I'm gonna make
some glass and then I'm gonna make some
enameled glass I think I only need to do
I need to I have no idea
um where was it without there's oh I
only need one oh that's convenient
I need computer chips though that was
the thing that I needed more of okay so
I need to make an animal go ahead and
make two cuz I know there's probably
something else I need an able to us I
think the Cyclops needs a lot of enabled
glass and I don't have enough for it but
I'm not gonna farm that up right now
because I don't have time to waste for
that and I'm about to run
power holy [ __ ] goddamnit oh thank you
thank you thank you thank you
big filtered water and me likey big
filtered water well I'll take some of
that thank you okay so I got that I got
the titanium and now I just need the
computer chips but I need enough power
to be able to do that
god dammit [ __ ] me never knew [ __ ] I
can't even open it oh good it's turning
into day time okay that's good all right
so I need computer chips which requires
silver or oh no I don't think I have
enough time I only have one ah [ __ ] I
gotta go get I gotta go get silver or
gray for me I'm not gonna waste my CMOS
energy on that I'm gonna go here I know
I just need to go down here and I need
to get all the things and the things and
do things to the things oh it's a
never-ending cycle of new stuff man I
wish I was cheating but I'm not gonna
have integrity there we go
oh that all I need I think that might be
all on you but I might as well get some
more while I'm here never know when
you're gonna need more batteries oh yes
please and thank you okay I think I got
enough silver I got really lucky on that
one so I didn't have to go around very
much
ha damn okay so I'm gonna make these
computer chips and then we're gonna make
the scanner room and then after an
offshoot of that we're gonna make the
moon pool but I'm not gonna worry about
that right now because I need table
coral which I have in here okay and then
we make two of these and we'll have
exactly what we need
Oh ain't kitty boink kitty boink I'm
glad I didn't do that in the wrong order
I think that's gonna be enough nope need
some titanium but I got plenty of that
boink boink boink and that's all she
wrote
oh I think this might be it okay this is
good let me get closer here okay so we
need a scanner room Oh what the frickin
dick
what was that how does that wait a
minute
why is it where's it being all weird
what what Kinect what the what the hell
is it doing connect to my goddamn base
why dontcha is it because I don't have
like what this isn't my co oh my god
this one is not very good on the
placement what the [ __ ] is happening why
won't this place exactly i no idea i
guess i guess beggars can't be choosers
here we go holy [ __ ] that was hard to
place but I got it it's over the
precipice but that's good I guess let's
go find out what it is cuz I have not
seen this yet alright making our way
downtown walking fast moving passing
them homebound all right what do we got
what do we have here
so I'll deposit quartz titanium lithium
lead oh that's cool that's cool that's
cool that's cool I don't know what it is
- aw
oh oh oh my god I just hit it
whoa look at this what oh oh I got my
own camera oh and it's spots lithium I
don't know what this means can I like I
grabbed it with I could it's just a
camera right it wouldn't be able to grab
it got two cameras oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that's so cool oh that's
so cool how do I get out of it though
how do I get out of it
[ __ ]
uh-uh okay there we go just got a head
escaped oh that's so cool metal salvage
can oh my god this is this would be
incredibly useful holy [ __ ]
okay so the scanner room is here and I
can even give it upgrade modules which I
believe you can increase its range uh
speed and HUD so all these are easy
upgrades because they only take computer
chips so I should be able to do that
okay with that I'm gonna end this
episode here because I have been playing
this for a while but that's how it
always goes whenever I play subnautica
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this and what I should do in the next
episode in the comments below and thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye Oh what the hell
where'd you come from you back up there
buddy okay so yeah I forgot me W doesn't
want any punk rock the resin poison
course ooze man through his body spacer
explodes Herc
oh God